today on stick to football it's time to
hand out hundred-dollar handshakes it's
time for hashtag defense for Heisman and
oh my god it is time for mock draft
Monday Connor the first of the year I'm
pretty excited about this thing yeah me
too this is gonna be obviously a long
show which everyone always likes we're
gonna cover every single pick of the
first round so if you're a Dolphins fan
or a Raiders fan you especially want to
stick around as you're on the board a
couple of times but every team should
Mack because well me and you were doing
this together live as we go back and
forth between picks it's interesting to
come across new trends what players got
into the first round that you didn't
expect and of course how many
quarterbacks Coe but before we get to
that of course we're gonna do our
hundred dollar handshakes and hash tag
defense for Heisman yeah it's gonna be a
good show today not a lot of news we're
gonna you know kind of cover what we saw
the weekend at college football the
Monday show is always gonna be a little
more NFL Draft heavy let's start with
those $100 handshakes the man and I got
a give one to our guy Sean Clifford the
quarterback for Penn State when we
picked this game on the Friday show I
think all of us a you and I both picked
Penn State but we were like I'm an I so
I don't know what Penn State is I don't
know their identity right now their
identity as Sean Clifford who absolutely
absolutely went off in a dominant win a
statement win over Maryland I think this
is a huge game for Sean Clifford it
maybe even establishes him now you know
as the leader of this team but yeah he
he played a hell of a game against
Maryland yeah he really did and is funny
when we previewed the games on the
Friday show you know we were nervous
about the Maryland offense and it turns
out that we were just we shouldn't have
been at all Penn State's offense came
out their defense came out what a
dominant effort from them and I mean
honestly besides Ohio State they have
surprisingly been the the you know the
best team in the Big Ten
besides Ohio State when everyone thought
it'd be Michigan Wisconsin all those
teams hanging around a great start for
Penn State my first one since I was at
this game on the west coast here the
Washington Huskies too for them tre
Adams really Matt really looked like a
franchise tackle seeing him in person as
a run blocker as a pass blocker he is
gigantic he moves very well the big
questions for him is gonna be those
medicals he's had a lot of injuries over
the years but in terms of talent and
traits and character he is the real deal
the real deal so it's exciting to see
him my other one from this game the
Washington secondary not an easy task
against these USC wide receivers they
played up in their face they press them
they played the ball in the air they
were physical coming downhill to help
against the USC run game these these
Washington DBS year after year they lose
guys early rounds in the draft all the
time last year is Byron Murphy Taylor
wrap this year they have players like
Elijah mold and Myles Bryant the list
really goes on and on and all of them
played very very well so they all get
$100 this weekend yeah it was very good
to see them step up in a tough game
against USC we we talked about you know
Mason Fink and they have Michael Pittman
jr. for them to step up that that
secondary is a big one how about this
guy Devon to Smith we talked so much
about Jerry Judy about Henry rugs you
cannot forget that Alabama goes for deep
a wide receiver that would probably be
in number one for most schools
Devon Smith a record-setting day 11
catches 274 yards in five touchdowns
you know just beat down against Ole Miss
and I've had a lot of people ask where's
Devon to Smith on your draft board I
have a big board that comes out Tuesday
morning so I asked people listen to this
show they can check that out tomorrow
but I've been told he's probably not
gonna come out I still went ahead and
ranked him just in case my man is a
first rounder if he comes out this year
based on everything I've seen thus far
he's a little skinny 6-1 175 but he lit
up Ole Miss
yeah entering this conversation of top
wide receivers it's crazy how quickly
that can happen and speaking of one that
entered the year in that conversation
and he's not going anywhere anytime soon
that's C D lamb it's weird Matt it's
actually felt like a quiet year for C D
lamb although he hasn't been quiet on
the field but jaylen hurts
Lincoln Riley even mr. Rambo over there
they've taken some of the spotlight and
CD had enough of that a three touchdown
weekend he looked great he looked strong
he was throwing guys off him after the
catch he has great hands he's a good
route runner he's perfect in that
offense
I still love C D lamb
one wide receiver and we'll get to that
later but as for this weekend take your
hundred dollars and go CD lamb you were
phenomenal no cd lamb is without a doubt
a first rounder and and we will get to
the point of the year where the heat
picks up on him and everybody's like oh
yeah wait he's still really really good
so glad you called him out I got to go
to Florida a team that I've been hard on
all year Phillip Bay Franks goes out
Kyle Trask comes in and this junior has
looked fantastic running this offense
last week 18 or 20 for a buck 88 in two
scores
he's just been fantastic I know they
played Towson it's like not a big deal
but I want to shout out Kyle trash
because he's been very good you can't
even go back to what they did against
Tennessee I know the volunteers are down
but that is a that's a rivalry game he
was 28 28 for almost 300 yards he has
been very very good for the Gators
coming in and relief this offense looks
like it's better with him under center
so I got a shout out Cal Trask I know I
know people are gonna get on us that
they beat Towson you go and play the
team in front of you at Cal Trask played
very well this week he said to come in
and step up and that's never easy to do
my next one and last one should be a
thousand dollar handshake Shuba Hubbard
oh my god 25 carries for almost 300
rushing yards it was ridiculous he
averaged almost 12 yards a carry and
this goes on just for this season this
was his third game over 200 rushing
yards third game so for the sophomore at
Oklahoma State he has been unstoppable
and I know we talked so much about
Thailand Wallace over the summer who's
been great but Hubbard continues to
carry such a so much volume of this
offense in a big way and he has
home-run-hitting ability I mean we're
seeing 70 80 yard kind of runs here from
Hubbard I loved what he did this weekend
and now he enters the Heisman
conversation as one of the most exciting
players in the country I love the I love
the kid we talked about him the week
before because Texas played all in the
state and I told you a mental I'm
terrified
Shuba Hubbard because he is so explosive
and when their passing game gets bogged
down they just turned a hand him the
ball yes amazing so I love to Mahavir my
last one how about Rashad Bateman we
talked a lot about Tyler Johnson and
receiver but Bateman in a close win for
Minnesota
overpour do to keep the
undefeated he goes six catches a buck 77
and two TDs a very good day for Bateman
who I think at times gets a little bit
overlooked in that offense but he had a
huge day Tyler Johnson's got a chance to
be a first rounder he had a good day as
well but Bateman really stole the show
when he saw a lot of single coverage so
he gets a hundred our handshake from me
how about defense for Heisman here's the
thing
chase young is the guy and he had
another sack he's got eight on the year
chase young looks like the predator like
if someone created a pass rusher it
would be chase young I think he's better
than Nick Bo so I think he's better the
Joey Bosa he might be better than Miles
Garrett because he's meaner
so obviously chase young is the guy he
deserves legitimate Heisman legit
eration but outside of that how are
people forgetting about his teammate
Jeff Okuda who's the best corner in
football and he showed you that against
Nebraska with two interceptions it's not
very often that people throw at him
Adrian Martinez made the mistake of
doing that a coup de main up a two picks
in a gigantic road win for the Buckeyes
absolutely gigantic Kakuta is just
almost the perfect corner at times his
great plays are as good as it gets at
the position and that's why you look at
him and ego he should be the next Ohio
State corner taken in the top ten like
Denzel Ward was he's that good Marshawn
Lattimore there's a tradition there I
know we talked about DBU all the time
for a million different schools but in
terms of NFL talent Ohio State at the
position right now is really churning it
out I want to give a shout out for
defense for Heisman because this guy is
going to finish the season with 300
tackles Evan Weaver on Cal that Cal
defense is surprising a lot of people
and I think Weaver has entered the
conversation maybe as a day to pick at
this point where you look at how quickly
he's getting to the football and
stopping the run I mean he's in that 15
to 20 tackle range it feels like every
single week he's the leader of the
middle of the defense I know they
suffered a crushing loss but he's the
guy that speaks up after it so if you're
looking for just somebody that is
putting up the numbers and making plays
he won't be in the real high-spending
conversation like chase young should be
but he needs to be in the hash tag
defense for Heisman
and that is Evan Weaver on a very
underrated kal defense yeah absolutely
he's someone I've had my eye on all year
and I know I got Jim naggy and the
Senior Bowl they definitely have their
eye on him too
all right Connor let's take a break a
quick first segment because oh baby it
is about to get crazy
the first mock draft Monday of the year
and I am on the clock when we come back
with the Miami Dolphins at number one
overall the Miami Dolphins are on the
clock with the first pick in the draft
just like they want to be they want to
do this let's not lie and as much as I
was encouraged by what we saw especially
early in the game from Josh Rosen in
week four with the first pick I have to
do it I'm taking to a-- from alabama
figure out what number he's gonna wear
after the fact he can wear three if you
want because he's probably not rocking
that 13 the Dan Marino made famous down
there but if the Dolphins have the first
pick I believe they have to take a
quarterback and tua is the top
quarterback in this class for me with a
bullet you could probably come close to
putting that in ink I love what he
brings on the field 11 he brings off the
field his touch accuracy is special his
instincts are special he's tough he's
mobile Connor to me to us everything you
want for the modern NFL and what what a
franchise quarterback should look like
and I'm with you all the way here Matt I
think this is kind of one of those years
where you and I will come to a complete
agreement on who the top quarterback in
the draft is very very easily
that is to a tongue of Eylau a-- and as
much as I believe in Josh Rosen I don't
think Miami's really gonna give him the
right chance and you only pick it number
one so many times so for the Dolphins go
get a guy like to or that can be that
franchise quarterback number two this
team has given them a run for their
money right now but they should not be
in the business of taking a quarterback
they should really try actually
developing Dwayne Haskins instead of
throwing him in there to die the
Washington Redskins at 2 its chase young
he's the best defensive player in this
draft he is a phenomenal pass rusher I
mean he might even be better than Nick
Bosa that's how good he is he he might
answer that miles Garrett conversation
he has strength he has speed he can bend
great hands he finishes plays I mean you
see the strip sacks not just normal sex
he's going for the football the Redskins
need talent right now they have added
talent to that defense over the year
but you're not gonna pass on a player
like chase young he's simply too good
yeah and that's it that's exactly where
it is he and Montes what would be a fun
combination as a well Ryan Kerrigan is
getting older with a good interior
exactly very good it's just Alabama down
there now yet in Chase yeah yeah number
three the Denver Broncos I know a lot of
folks have said what you have to think
quarterback here I don't know that
that's the case because they did draft
drew Locke in the second round last year
I know was it wasn't their first
second-round pick so but I do believe
they like the future they're they at
least want to see what they have so I'm
gonna go a different direction and add a
dynamic young receiver to this already
solid young receiving corps I'm puttin
Jerry Judy here I've said it before he's
the closest thing I've ever seen to
Odell Beckham jr.
he's so electric his brakes are so
smooth what he's able to do as a route
runner is incredibly special he is
surrounded by a lot of talent at Alabama
so no he's probably not gonna break any
records in terms of catches but like
last year when he leave he had 68
catches he won the Biletnikoff Award
everyone understands he's the best
receiver in college football he has a
chance to be the best receiver prospect
I've ever evaluated Jerry Judy's that
good that's why he's going to the
Broncos at number three even though it's
not the biggest need on the board for
them it is the best fit yeah that one
breaks my heart a little bit cuz I was
hoping he would fall the for for the New
York Jets for me here and get Sam Donald
the number one wide receiver but since
that's not happening the Jets need
offensive line help I mean they really
do you see how poor that group has been
this year Kelvin Beecham is gonna hit
free agency so they're gonna have a
pretty big hole at left tackle the pick
for me here is Andrew Thomas from
Georgia is he perfect right now no not a
lot of offensive line prospects are but
you see what he can do in the run game
it's special and they have a guy there
named levy on bail that needs help
so Andrew Thomas he gets to the second
level of the field he gets to the third
level of the field sometimes which is
amazing I think he'll really develop and
pass protection at left tackle and this
is a team that they need a guy that can
just get in there on the offensive line
and contribute right away and that's
exactly what Thomas could do love Andrew
Thomas he is a fantastic player number
five the Cincinnati Bengals like the
Miami Dolphins I'll say this about Andy
Dalton if they're drafting in the top
five I believe they have to look at
quarterback now this is not a move I
would make I want to reiterate
doctor after what we think will happen
not what we would do even in this point
of the year where it's September 30th
we're recording this I would not make
this pick but I believe the Cincinnati
Bengals will because they are desperate
for a franchise quarterback I many of
them Justin a Herbert from Oregon
Herbert looks the part he's tall he has
a strong arm he's athletic
he is accurate to some degree I worry
about his mental toughness but I could
see Zack Taylor as long as he's still
the head coach wanting his version of
Jared golf and I do think that's the
ceiling for Justin Herbert is it Jared
golf kind of guy the problem for me is
the floor is playing Gaborik so if you
split the middle I don't know if that's
an upgrade over Andy Dalton but I will
at least say I do think that they're
gonna take that shot this year to try to
to try to improve because they're stuck
right now at the position they have some
young weapons and Tyler Boyd and Joe
Mixon they've invested well they've
picked fairly well on defense they need
a quarterback they can get them over the
top so I think they swing for the fences
in the first round this year and what
Jonah Williams coming back next year
they might have a little bit of a
foundation on the offensive line for a
young quarterback to play behind so that
pick would not surprise me at all number
six this is the minka Fitzpatrick pick
essentially because the Dolphins are
picking sixth year where the Steelers
would of so that pick right now is a
juicy top-10 pick and I'm going with
Tristan Dwarfs here from Iowa I think
he's interesting because we don't know
if he's a top-10 lock right now but I
think he has all the traits you look for
in an offensive tackle and if the
Dolphins are taking Toa
like you had at number one Matt you are
not throwing to a tongue of I lava
behind this offensive line you are not
doing it Laremy Tunsil is gone I know
some Dolphins fans are probably banging
their heads thinking well we traded our
franchise tackle and now we're drafting
a maybe franchise tackling the top ten
that's what happens and I think worse
could be a very good player the Dolphins
need a foundation for when to it gets
there if they don't take chase young
number one overall they take to a you
got to start building up that offense
and that has to start on the offensive
line no it absolutely does and again a
lot of people say well that guy's not a
top 10 player on your board or whatever
we're expecting guys to float up the
board like they always do Daniel Jones
wasn't in our top 10 last year he went
six overall so
players float especially guys at premium
positions number seven the Arizona
Cardinals there I wanted to go offensive
line here but we've taken the two best
off the board here recently I look
instead to defense we haven't seen Pat
Pete this year because this is submit a
suspension excuse me they did draft
Byron Murphy last year I still believe
corner is a need for them they are one
of the teams that was rumored to be very
interested in Jalen Ramsey I'm gonna
give them Jeffery Acuna from Ohio State
we talked about him earlier in the show
I believe he's the best corner in this
draft I think he's the best Ohio State
corner I've ever seen that's better than
Denzel Ward better than Marchand Latimer
he's that talented so Jeff Okuda here to
the Cardinals again probably not the
biggest need for this team but given
what's available to get a guy who I
think could be an all-pro Corner as a
rookie at seven like you can't get that
lucky Steve time number eight the
Atlanta Falcons here I think the Vic
Beasley era is gonna come to an end
after the season why not upgrade get
yourself an AJ epinet that is a very
different kind of pass rusher than Vic
Beasley epinet says game is converting
speed to power he will drive offensive
tackles right into the lap of the
quarterback the numbers might not be the
flashy he doesn't have the chase young
eight sacks right but in terms of
ProTools productivity and a complete
player run defender a pass rusher a
three down player I think epinet
I don't know what the future is for Dan
Quinn but if Dan Quinn is still there
and has a hand in making this pick
epinet is the perfect player for him you
have God yes he absolutely is a little
bit scary even number nine the
Indianapolis Colts is surprised to see
them picking this early but everyone in
the AFC South is two and two this
morning so this is where they are when I
look at this offense when T Y Hilton is
gone they it's just a different team no
one get the job done without him so I'm
gonna give them a little bit of help at
the receiver position they need it badly
t Higgins going here I thought about C D
lamb I thought about Henry rugs but I
still think t Higgins is the most
complete receiver in the class outside
of Jerry Judy Clemson has struggled this
year especially in the passing game so
Higgins has been I think forgotten about
to some degree because the numbers are
exceptional I mean when it comes around
to the combine t Higgins is gonna remind
everybody he's really good at his job
and that clemson has a track record of
putting
guys into the NFL at receiver and being
really really good and he's gonna be the
next one in this group yeah and what is
up with the magical powers the Andrew
Luck had we're only Eric Ebron can catch
the ball from I think is amazing no
other quarterback it works for but
Andrew Luck Eric Ebron caught it felt
like everything in his career what a
bizarre bizarre game for the Colts
alright ten the Jacksonville Jaguars the
fighting Gardner Minshew is my goodness
this team is seems fun to watch there's
really no way around it yes we have them
at ten right here get Gardner a dude at
wide receiver and that dude is CD Lam I
talked about earlier in the show
hundred-dollar handshake CD Lam I mean
he really does everything you want I
think the only thing what CD Lam is he
will probably run a very very mediocre
forty time I could see him being a four
or five five and maybe I'll be wrong but
what it looks like on tape he doesn't
always blow by people but he is
phenomenal at the catch point he's very
strong after the catch and he's a good
route runner where when you have all
three of those things you still gain
separation and like we always say we say
this about T Higgins ly you know being
above the rim kind of receiver he's
always open four feet over his head so I
love CD lamb and I think this is a team
where they have a lot of energy right
now with a young quarterback and keep
investing by putting young weapons
around him oh I absolutely love that pic
and you're right with CD lamb I have no
idea what he's gonna run but he's just
so creative after the catch that he
makes up for it number 11 the Baltimore
Ravens and one thing that I'll say about
this team they've been so good
especially offensively I really think
they miss CJ Moseley and I believe that
we saw that yesterday soon at loss to
the Cleveland Browns
so does the Jets right I'm gonna give
them a guy who can replace CJ Moseley
and be a different type of player
especially with coverage in the middle
of the field Isiah Simmons from Clemson
you you've seen him play safety we see
him now playing middle linebacker he's
just a special type of athlete that
would be a great anchor for the middle
of the defense here I like some of the
young guys the Ravens half but this line
back in court as a whole and I include
the edge rushers in that they need to
step up and play to their draft position
someone like a Isiah Simmons could
really come in and put this entire unit
together and complete
it I love him as a player he's got a
chance to be a top five or top six guy
for me when it's all said and done yeah
he's like if Mark Baron was actually
really really good like a position
Chancellor had played linebacker yep
Shaq Thompson a little bit kind of the
motet but he has a chance to be way
better than all those guys and I think
Simmons in a Baltimore Ravens uniform is
beyond perfect number 12 the New York
Giants interesting to start for the
Giants they are now 2 and 2 right now so
we have no idea where this team will
ultimately end up picking but in the top
15 right here
they let Landon Collins walk Jabril
peppers had a really good game against
Washington but he's been all over the
place I did not think he played well
against Buffalo and even if you want to
keep him that's fine get a guy next to
him that guy is Grant Delpit Grant
Delpit could still finish as a top 10
player in this class safeties tend to
fall sometimes what I like about Delpit
for the Giants is he could play slot
corner for you they need some help at
the corner position he can play outside
linebacker the way the Jets used Jamal
as a pass rusher or just somebody that
can spy or even an outside run defender
or you could play true free safeties so
for the Giants they need talent on the
defense right now because you're not
gonna get to play the Washington
Redskins every week and whatever's going
on at quarterback for them Grant Delpit
could be an answer there yeah I've been
disappointed by Delpit this year that's
a lot of plays yep something mellow and
I talked about off-air of the week
inside guys who haven't done what we
expected and Grant dumped what was one
of them number 13 they lost Angeles
chargers on the clock here one thing
that I look at the board the players who
are still available one thing I would
love is to give Phillip Rivers
a little more help I know some people
are like why not take a quarterback in
the future I just I don't know about the
if they're the team that's gonna do
something like that they did draft
Easton stick in the fifth round last
year I want to give them speed in the
slot I think they really miss Tyrell
Williams I'm giving them Henry rugs who
might be the fastest player I've ever
seen and I say that knowing that John
Ross Tyreke he'll I think he might be
faster than both those guys put him in
the slot with Keenan Allen who's the
best route runner in football with Mike
Williams on the outside and this offense
is terrifying I thought about running
back here I don't think they'll draft or
to replace Melvin Gordon they just don't
value that spot enough give me Henry
rugs and just you're gonna have to beat
the Chiefs you're gonna have to be able
to score that's just all there is to it
so I think rugs in this offense maybe
that's just me wanting them to be
creative but I think he would be a
fantastic fit yeah and that Austin
Eckler guy is pretty decent huh it's
unbelievable how well that's worked out
for them all right fourteen the
Philadelphia Eagles this team needs a
corner I am not completely sold that CJ
Henderson is the shut down premiere
corner yet but I think he has all the
tools to develop into a good one and the
Eagles really are great at developing
players and he probably is the best one
on the board right here so for the
Eagles I'm going with Henderson great
athlete he has lengthiest recovery speed
I know they've been so beat up at the
position but even without that this is a
team in the offseason that is gonna be
looking to improve their secondary and
CJ Henderson makes a lot of sense at
this point in the middle of the draft he
really does unless they trade this pic
for Jalen Ramsey which is a possibility
after sitting here Tuesday morning it
could still happen
number 15 the Tennessee Titans
I love Marcus Mariota and I think he's
probably a great guy he's gonna be a
really good backup quarterback somewhere
else next year the Titans have to move
on they have to and I think they need to
get away from that mentality of let's
find a conservative guy who's just gonna
move the ball and not turn it over
you don't want Alex Smith you need
someone who is a firecracker who can
push the ball down the field who will
take chances and make plays I'm giving
them Joe burrow and I know that a couple
months ago we talked about Joe burrow
and we kept saying I need to see more I
don't know what Joe burrow is I've seen
a month of college football right now I
like Joe burrow and I think he is on a
trajectory that will end up with a
first-round pick now the wheels could
fall off once we get into Sec play that
is absolutely possible but where he is
right now
to me looks like a first rounder I think
he goes to Mobile Alabama tears up the
Senior Bowl and makes himself enough
money to be a top 15 pick he's the kind
of guy I would want driving the bus with
AJ Brown there with Derrick Henry in the
backfield with an offensive line that
has some
pieces I think it'll be a lot better
once Taylor Luanne's off suspension Joe
burrow in that offense is so much more
fun and there's so many more
possibilities than what we're getting
right now a marcus mariota yeah and you
could see Mike Vrabel absolutely falling
in love with a guy like Joe burrow that
can go out and win you the game at times
and we just unfortunately had we wanted
Mariota to be great and I just it
doesn't feel like it's happening so it's
tough alright sixteen to round out the
top half of the first round of this
draft Carolina Panthers let's get him a
weapon this is not just a wide receiver
he's not just a running back I know he's
listed at wide receiver LaVista Chenault
does everything and I know if you're a
Panthers fan you're probably sitting
there and saying yeah well I heard that
with DJ more I heard that occur to
Samuel
I think shouldn't all as long as he
could stay healthy can really be a
difference maker the way he breaks
tackles he hasn't been in the greatest
situation in Colorado at times I know
it's not like Montez is a bad
quarterback or anything like that I just
think the targets haven't always been
there for him I think and you see what
he could do on special teams Chenal is a
really really exciting player now if the
panthers loose a couple more games here
it becomes the t hagen CD lamb
conversation instead of the Chenal
conversation but he's no consolation
prize he is a really really impressive
playmaker the Tampa Bay Buccaneers are
on the clock at 17 I don't know where to
go with this team it might be a
quarterback it could be a running back
for now I'm gonna address the elephant
in the room and that's the offensive
line that has been not good I'm gonna
Creed Humphrey here a little bit of an
unknown at Oklahoma the only returning
starter to this offensive line I you put
him in he could play guard he could play
center I know
alie market is really good and
underrated but they got to do something
upfront to fix this a line I think what
everyone's wondering right now has Bruce
Arians unlocked Jameis Winston I'm not
either I'm definitely not ready to say
that either but it's why you stayed away
from quarterbacks we're still wondering
right now 18 the Minnesota Vikings
listen Adam Thielen it clearly does not
approve of Kirk Cousins we're going with
Jacob Eason here and like I said got to
see him play this weekend that arm is
lively I wouldn't be shocked if he goes
back to school they believe next year in
Washington that
they have a special group but the NFL
comes calling for quarterbacks and Jacob
Eason has a cannon he's gonna be highly
valued by the NFL thought he moves
better than I expected for someone
that's six six to 35 he moved very well
so an exciting player that's Eason and
even if he s a city year over there
that's fine but if you're Minnesota you
need a guy that can really air things
out for your offense yeah and get Adam
Thielen someone who can throw the ball
number 19 the Detroit Lions I still
think they need corner help again
another team that they were in on the
minka Fitzpatrick talks
I think polisena Tebow the Stanford
corner we're gonna see in about two
months when we get to the Cal Stanford
game
I love his ability he is prototypical
size prototypical ball skills had an
amazing 2018 season Stanford knows how
to coach them up I think the Lions
continue to add on defense I did think
about receiver here to add to what they
have with Kenny Galilei and Marvin Jones
but no one on the board at this spot
that I really fell in love with and they
would make for one of the best
secondaries in football because Justin
Coleman is playing out of his mind yes
yeah so I would love and he's more of a
slot guy I would love that pick to
bolster up that unit 20 the Seattle
Seahawks steal of the mock draft right
here this is the steal of the mock draft
they've missed on running backs before I
think it's safe to say they will not
miss on this guy DeAndre swift he is a
Christian McCaffrey level running back
prospect for this Seattle offense he can
run he can catch he could pass protect
he could do it all this would be
extremely exciting for the Seahawks to
get him this late yeah people are not
gonna be happy with you for taking
another running back but they do need it
number 21 the Cleveland Browns everyone
knows what they should do the question
will be is anyone of value on the board
they need to address the offensive line
I'm gonna give them Alex Leatherwood the
next left tackle from Alabama a lot like
Jonah Williams who played right tackle
now he's on the left side
I like Leatherwood I don't know if he
comes out this year that's probably the
only question I have but my god left
tackle has to be the clear-cut biggest
need for the Cleveland Browns assuming
everyone comes back next year because
they have all the pieces elsewhere but
they're just getting Baker Mayfield and
the rest of the offense killed because
they can't protect right now so
Leatherwood solves a very big problem in
Cleveland yeah I think of you're a
Browns fan get used to offensive line
Mach to your team the entire year
leading up to the giraffe 22 the Raiders
here their first pick of the first round
I'm a Derrick brown this is a BPA
approach I know Raiders fans might not
be overly excited about a defensive
lineman but Brown has been a game record
for Auburn this year he really has and I
think for Oakland if you're not picking
in the top 10 or top 15 where you can
get one of these elite quarterbacks for
Gruen to work with you got to go be PA
keep stacking it with good players Brown
is probably maybe the best interior one
of the group in this draft yeah I think
he is it's not a great defensive tackle
class Derrick brown definitely has a
chance to make himself some money number
23 the Dallas Cowboys they cannot
I don't think pay everyone Jerry Jones
might prove me wrong but I think we're
gonna see someone like Byron Jones just
have to be let go because of salary cap
constraints this is where you can draft
to replace and I look at someone like
Christian Fulton who's had a very good
year at LSU he is a first rounder in my
opinion would be a very good value here
with with Jordan Lewis with Tobey
illuzzi a with Anthony Brown he could
come in and fill out this unit I believe
he could be a number one corner in the
NFL hey play a lot like today vyas white
honestly that type of mid to late
first-round guy high character very
sticky underneath a physical corner
exactly what Dallas needs they're gonna
have to keep hitting on these late
first-round picks but they have shown
that they're able to do that yeah they
really have with Wilma clay they're just
absolutely crushing it 24 the Green Bay
Packers apologies if I butchered his
last name but the TCU offensive tackle
Lewis and yang I think when you look at
this position for Green Bay right now
it's been so impressive over the years
how how good these guys have been but at
some point you got to look to the future
and they started doing that last year by
adding to the interior now you have to
get a tackle even if he doesn't play
right away I think it's something that
you really have to consider because they
want Aaron Rodgers to play for a very
long time they're into his old age and
you need to protect a guy like Rodgers
that's been hurt so to get somebody that
has all the traits of being elite past
protector at this point of the draft I
think it's a must for the Packers yeah
it really is they just have to address
that number 20
five of the Miami Dolphins we have them
taking tua and Tristan worse
so offense offense I'm gonna stay on
offense because they need so much help
on that side of the ball you look at the
run game it's just not there
whether it's Kenyan Drake whether it's
you know Marc Walton it doesn't matter
who's back there they need someone who
could carry the ball Jonathan Taylor
just scores touchdown as we've seen it
for three years now at Wisconsin yes he
has a high amount of carries that's why
he's available at number 25 overall when
you are 220 pounds and they're gonna run
a legitimate high 4-3 and have rushed
for over 4,000 yards in two years you
should not be available at 25 the
Dolphins get a steal here and someone
who could take pressure off our guy - at
quarterback well I have the same story
for the Buffalo Bills here at 26 because
they get Travis etn who is just a
phenomenal runner talk about having
amazing outside bursts I think if you're
looking at the bills right now if they
had a good quarterback they would be a
contender to win the AFC and I fully
mean that Josh Lowe now so bad yesterday
that was awful and New England has a
great defense they're well prepared for
you but Allen is a game killer for them
the bills might have the best defense in
the AFC right now and they have players
that are getting it done on the
offensive side of the ball and in that
it's one game it's one game but that was
a game where Josh Allen lost them the
game and if you're gonna keep rolling
with him you want to develop him I get
it you got to put even more pieces
around him and Travis eats he and they
neither young running back him and
Singletary can complement each other for
the future it'd be a lot of fun to watch
them together oh yeah I mean it's it's
almost like they're young shady McCoy
but Frank Gore will still be the
starting running back for them we all
know it's gonna happen we all know it is
number 27 the Los Angeles Rams
with a Terry Buccaneers score 50 on you
you have problems defensively I know a
lot of that was set up by interceptions
but I think the middle of this defense
needs a boost not that alec Ogletree was
great but they haven't been the same
without someone good in the middle I'm
gonna give them Dylan Moses who sneaks
into the first round here I know yes the
ACL injury
I would project the he is ready to roll
by April just as how Alabama guys are
having that surgery early I think he's
gonna be just fine
and let's not forget
I was looking at him as a top ten pick
before he got hurt so getting him at 27
he's really good value for the Rams also
I just want to follow up that I crushed
the Niang pronunciation Oh attaboy
I found a pronunciation guide Fri like
the PDF of nine hundred pages I was like
there it is
all right yeah Dylan Moses though is an
interesting one because of the injury
we've seen a lot of guys though that are
that talented it doesn't matter if they
get cleared by the medical teams know
what they are already and they could
still go on the top forty picks here the
Raiders are up on the clock again it's
always fun when you get the Raiders
twice because their fan base is
completely unforgiving if you mess up
the rights so I'm gonna double down here
this is really interesting because
Jordan love to me is the quarterback of
this class that can end up going top
five he could end up going day three
right now we've seen great from Jordan
Love and we've seen some bad but in
terms of talent he can do it all he
really can he has an arm and I've never
met a couple of weeks ago we sat down
very early in the morning before the
show and you were like man I just got
through coach's film of Jordan Love and
I liked a lot of what I saw and I think
for me it's been the same for him where
if they're gonna keep trying Derek are
get somebody behind him that you can
develop on the fly you know and I think
love at this point of the draft is the
guy that you do that with and we'll also
keep an eye on how much Jalen hurts
continues to grow yeah Jalen hurts is
the one to watch but I think Jordan love
is being slept on right now because just
because he's at Utah State a lot of
people don't know exactly what he has to
offer but his traits to me absolutely
look like someone who could be a first
rounder so I'm with you on that at
number thirty overall excuse me 29
overall the New Orleans Saints gosh I
want them to have another receiver I
miss the days when Mike Thomas had a
good running mate and especially if
we're gonna eventually see life after
Drew Brees
I think you have to have weapons you
have to have targets you look at the
Saints d-line dominated last night I did
think about giving them Kayla Vaughn
chase on from LSU who has been quiet
this year but I think has some
first-round traits but I'm gonna go wide
receiver here because I think they need
someone opposite Michael Thomas to draw
some coverage away jaylen rigueur from
TCU not the biggest guy but a very good
route runner a very good hands catcher
on braking routes
he would complement what Mike Thomas
does especially outside of the red zone
he's some of they could be a very good
yards after catch receiver number 30 the
New England Patriots don't know if
they'll be picking here with how things
usually go for the Patriots but they do
pick this early for them I went with
Tyler B Aatish and we got to see him
when we were down at Wisconsin against
Michigan the Patriots offensive line has
been eaten alive by injuries where if
you can stack the board with more
interior talent viata sh'zazz good as he
gets in this class for interior players
and he fits the mold of what they want
to be it looks like at times they can be
this power running team
now that brady and brady hasn't lost a
step but as he gets older you've seen
them load up on running backs and really
be able to run the ball down your throat
like they did - it seemed like the
chargers last year in the postseason so
New England is one of those teams
they'll just keep taking offensive
linemen year after year and they'll
develop them and you don't even have to
develop this guy cuz be Aatish is ready
to step on the field from day one yeah
he absolutely is he is one of my
favorite players in college football -
just watch like just he dominates
dominates absolutely does number 31 the
undefeated only undefeated team in the
NFC the San Francisco 49ers we'll see
how long that lasts the schedule looks
pretty tough coming up Safety's in need
I love guys like Tchaikovsky tart they
just can't seem to stay healthy Richard
Sherman continues to be amazing out on
the outside I like a killer Weatherspoon
at corner I'm gonna go safety here
though Xavier McKinney from Alabama
getting lost in the shuffle a little bit
because Alabama is so deep this year so
talented I think McKinney is a very good
safety prospect though a great fit for
this Roberts Taylor defense he has the
range to play over the top
he's physical enough to help you in the
run game but I love what Xavier McKinney
could be as a late first round pick
someone I think would project as a
rookie starter in this defense yeah it's
crazy there's been no hype about him at
all so far and this happens every year
because he's on a great defense and then
everyone watches the film ago that guy
is jumping out what are the odds 30 31
and 32 are all three of Matt's favorites
in the maze in a row you play too
I should have let you finish the entire
model right the Kansas City Chiefs this
is a really interesting one because here
Matt say it every week they're one of
those themes that could be on the jaylen
Ramsey sweepstakes and if they could
trade this pick for him do it 90 million
times at it set out of 90 million
dollars but I went with Bryce hall here
who I think is a fringe first-round
player they need cornerback help he's
physical what he runs is gonna dictate
so much of where he goes in the draft
but he's been playing at a high level
for this Virginia team for a while now I
mean he could have declared last year
opted to stay so the Chiefs needs
secondary helps still they really do and
I think Brice Hall in this situation is
the best corner on the board it is draft
on draft time we got some fun ones this
week from Gustavo Olguin the first one
as a USC fan waiting to be cured of clay
Helton who would be your top five
coaches you would want to bring in in
the offseason to improve your football
team
well can we get crazy with it I think we
get crazy
it's obviously Urban Meyer though it is
Urban Meyer I mean we've heard there's
been rumors like crazy about this
already but let's do it let's do some
other ones just in case like I don't
think this is a team that can pry away a
Matt Campbell from Iowa State
even though in terms of like brand that
seems like a jump Matt Campbell is is a
Midwest kind of guy he's not going to
USC I'd be surprised right Matt rule
just signed an extension which I don't
think we'll see him finish that out in
2027 to Baylor I think he'll be in the
NFL before then what direction would you
go here man who do you think they have a
chance of getting well that's like this
is still USC and they've been down like
this is still a really good job I would
call Jim Harbaugh and say hey it's not
working at Michigan what would it take
to get you to leave Michigan because I
could see the Wolverines being like ah
you know like we would let him go
because it's just not good yeah to a
completely different conference right so
just get him out of there get him out of
the Midwest
I don't like that's where I would go
because I don't think you could call
Oklahoma and say hey Lincoln Riley you
want to come here he'd be like not
happening I don't want to go there why
would I go to USC so you have to like be
somewhat aware of who you are I think
you know like PJ Fleck would be an
interesting name was the one that came
to mind that's such a big jump even for
him though like to go from Minnesota to
USC like that's a massive jump so it's
tough it really USC's in a really
difficult spot because it's still a
blueblood program but they're so bad and
there's no patience there and it's right
you know the like unknown route with
clay Hilton like let's promote this guy
he clearly didn't work now this one
would not be a USC hire but where do you
we got a seat Jim Leonard go somewhere
soon right Oh Jimmy's got to get a job
you know that no that's not you see job
defense coordinator for Wisconsin no
yeah he'll he'll land somewhere very
very quickly I don't think that's the
right spot for him no it's not it's not
but you wouldn't go there
I'm sorry USC fans like yeah I mean you
know there's just there's not that like
oh I would think like young offensive
mind which is I think why they tried to
do the the Kliff Kingsbury like almost
coaching waiting thing [ __ ] he might be
available after this year you know I
yeah they could have Adam GaSe and also
but to your point about Harbaugh he can
recruit on the west coast
yes Washington Washington is doing a
great job
stealing recruits that u.s. USC should
get right UCLA is not even a concern
right now so if you're us seen you get
Harbaugh for how not great as a men
disaster not not great things have been
in Michigan Harbaugh would do a really
good job there he really would but
that'll be Urban Meyer so Jeremy got in
with our next question do you guys feel
outcomes of games for example Ole Miss
in Alabama this weekend our teams like
Alabama taking their eye off of their
current opponent and looking ahead on
their schedule I mean I definitely
happens Alabama was still dominant I
mean I think two or through six
touchdowns the second half good yeah I
definitely think it happens we talk
about it every week we pick games if I
go this might be a trap game or
a team that they could be overlooking
them so yeah I definitely do think that
even though they I think they let Ole
Miss score 31 points which is a little
more than then you would expect Bama to
give up I mean yeah it definitely
happens I think I even think you look at
Clemson North Carolina
it's like Clemson there's something in
their head they're they're just not as
explosive as they were last year and
they they really should be they didn't
lose anyone offensively and they're just
they look so stale I wonder how often
it's that that they're feeling that
pressure a little bit
yeah Clemson does look flat for a team
that hasn't lost in a very long time
they just look flat I don't know what it
is right now and I think it's a great
question because like if anyone is
playing Rutgers how can you get up for
that game week and maybe it's different
for a current athlete maybe you get up
for every week and everyone's move
differently but like it god I mean
everyone's just steamrolling Rutgers at
this point
so anyways next one from Elias called
Orson who is a higher up side in terms
of pure talent between Jacob Eason and
Justin Herbert how likely do you think
it is for Eason to catch up to Herbert
in the quarterback rankings well because
this show comes out the night before my
big board does I'm gonna give you a
little bit of a spoiler they're not that
far apart for me I need Justin Herbert's
overrated I really do and you'll see
that when my big board comes out Tuesday
morning I like Easton's tools I've heard
it's tough because I've only watched I
haven't yet watched the USC tape I'll
probably do that today the games I've
watched he has looked really good but
I'm still stuck on a lot of what people
have told me about him which as everyone
knows for a longtime listener a reader
that factors in a lot with quarterbacks
because the people who are making these
school visits and who are around these
players you have to trust their insights
into the character and the personality
of a guy and I think both of these guys
are interesting players from that
perspective like with Herbert there's
talks that he might be a little you know
I mentally solved and just not very
tough with Eason it's just like he might
not be the best decision maker on or off
the field so I think it's very possible
but I do think guys like Joe burrow and
join love or probably right now have a
lot more lot more steam in terms of NFL
circles then Herbert and Eason do
interesting yeah I think her Herbert
almost has had the problem of staying
too long
I really probably should have come out I
mean we're looking at it we're just like
yeah I I just don't see greatness right
now after being touted as a number one
potential number one pick for three
years I just yeah it's it's hard to see
it all right last one of the day hear
from Dan alter but a lot of people
collectively agreeing that Clemson
doesn't look like the number one team
could we use this as a case to get rid
of preseason rankings and not ranked
teams until a week or two into the
season I'm okay with that I mean yeah
practically but someone's gonna do it
we're gonna do it yes yeah it's gonna do
it you know like it's still gonna happen
I think that preseason rankings are
gonna go anywhere let's just stop taking
them so seriously like who cares where
you're ranked preseason week one and I
actually I tweeted about this over the
weekend if someone said you know like
the rankings that matter are gonna come
out soon these aren't it and so it is
kind of like that these are like NFL
power rankings that we put out on Monday
morning it's like no one really cares
but it's just a guideline for an opinion
of which team is best it's usually based
on biases or who looks good last year
after week five or six it all gets torn
up and and really done over again and my
opinion Clemson's probably like the
fifth best team in football right now I
think Bama Ohio State Oklahoma LSU maybe
Georgia and then I would put Clemson I
know they're undefeated they've won 20
straight games down a ton of first-round
picks on this team they're still not
playing a good football they're not and
maybe they'll get hot at the right time
again I mean that's what matters down to
yeah that's all that matters right now
maybe they they need a big game to get
up for like we saw a national title game
just shocked people last year what how
emphatic ly they stomped out Alabama but
that is our show Matt our first mock
draft Monday in a very long time how are
we feeling feels good to be back man I'm
excited to dig in and we're gonna start
fixing teams like the Miami Dolphins
very very soon like you said on a recent
show and the Oakland Raiders that
multiple picks so it's gonna be fun to
dig in and do this I want to remind
people if you fade it to the end of the
show though Melo and I will be
tailgating a Sunday night before Sunday
Night Football in Lot J at Arrowhead
Stadium it's gonna be a great time if
you remember the RV we took to the Ohio
State Michigan game we'll be in that
again it's a
big red white and blue RV and lodge a
you won't be able to miss it be a great
time it's free just come hang out we're
gonna have some stuff to give away we'll
be doing the show live from Arrowhead